- [Instructor] Let's
say we're a professor at
a university of a statistics class
and we administer an exam
and we're curious about the relationship
between the amount of
time that students study
and the percent that they
get correct on the test.
So, what we do is we
grade all of the exams.
We set up these buckets.
The time studied, zero to 20 minutes,
21 to 40 minutes, 41 to 60 minutes,
or greater than 60 minutes.
So, those are our buckets for
the amount of time studying.
And then, we also create
buckets for the percent correct.
So, zero to 19% correct,
20 to 39% correct, 40 to 59% correct,
60 to 79% correct, or 80 to 100% correct.
And then, we figure out what percentage of
our entire student population
falls into each of these categories.
So, for example, 2% of our
students studied 21 to 40 minutes
and got between 80 and 100% on the exam.
16% studied for more than an
hour, more than 60 minutes,
and got between 40 and 59% on the exam.
So, what I have, right over here,
this is a two-way table.
It's describing a joint distribution.
The joint distribution between...
You can view these as two variables.
The time studied and the percent correct.
Now, what we're gonna introduce
ourselves to in this video
is two new ideas outside of
just the joint distribution.
One is the idea of the
marginal distribution.
I will write this in green.
Marginal distribution.
And this is the idea
of, "Okay, I can see...
I can break down my class based
on both of these variables,
but what if I only care
about the distribution
of just the percent correct.
I don't wanna break it
down by time studied."
Well, if I wanna figure out
the distribution of percent correct,
I can just total up each of these rows
and I would end up with this
distribution right over here.
And, just to make it clear,
I would see that 20% of my
students got 80 to 100% correct.
I would see that 30% of my students got
between 60 and 79% correct.
I see that 35% of my students
get between 40 and 59% correct.
I think you see where this is going.
10% of my students got
between 20 and 39% correct.
And then, finally, 5% of my students
got between zero and 19% correct.
All we did is we totaled
up each of these rows.
And, notice, these now add up to 100.
This describes the distribution
of the scores in my class.
If someone were to just
give you this column,
you would say, "Okay, 20% of
my students got 80 to 100%."
you don't know the breakdown by
how much they actually studied.
You would say 5% got between
zero and 19% on my test,
but you wouldn't know what the breakdown
of that 5% based on how much they studied.
So, this type of distribution...
It's called a marginal distribution,
because you can view it as
it's written in the margin
right over here that we total these rows
and we write it in the margin.
Now, there's another
marginal distribution.
We could figure out the distribution
of the amount of time
people studied in my class.
And so, if we cared about that,
that we would total up
each of these columns.
We would total up each of the columns
and look at this right over here.
We would say, "Okay, 7% of my class
studied between zero and 20 minutes.
15% of my class studied
between 21 and 40 minutes.
43% of my class studied
between 41 and 60 minutes.
35% of my class studied
more than 60 minutes.
More than an hour."
And, if I just look at
this marginal distribution,
this marginal distribution
of the time studied,
I'm not able to get the
breakout of that 35%
that studied more than an hour.
If I just looked at that
marginal distribution...
Once again, it's called that
because I'm writing in the margin,
in this case, below our table.
If I just looked at that
marginal distribution,
I would not know the breakdown
by the actual percent correct.
Now, there's another type of distribution
that's related to these
joint distributions
or you could say these two-way tables.
And that's thinking about the
distribution of one variable
given what bucket you fall
in for the other variable.
So, let me write this down.
So, if I wanna say the
distribution of scores given...
All right let me write it this way.
Distribution of scores
among those who studied,
let's say, more than 60 minutes.
So, where would I get that?
Well, it's all right.
I'll go to the column of the people
who studied more than 60 minutes
and then I'd find this
distribution of scores.
And I see it right over here.
Among the folks who studied
more than 60 minutes,
I have this distribution of scores.
So, in that group, 10% got 80 to 100,
5% got 60 to 79, 16& got 40 to 59,
none of them, 0% got 20 to
39, and 4% got 0 to 19%.
And so, this distribution of one variable
given a bucket that you're
falling into another variable.
This is called a conditional distribution.
'Cause you're getting a
distribution conditioned
on a value of another variable.
So, this right over here is
a conditional distribution.
So, the big idea here, you
have this two-way table.
We're trying to relate
how two variables...
We're trying to study how two variables
relate to each other.
If we care about just the distribution
of one of the variables, for
example, the time studied,
we can sum up the columns here
and we would get this
marginal distribution.
If we cared about the
distribution of percent correct,
we could sum up the rows
and get that distribution.
And, if we wanted, in the
case that I just talked about,
the distribution of one variable...
The distribution of one variable,
in this case, the distribution of scores,
the distribution of percent correct,
given a certain value conditioned on
a value of another variable.
Well, that's going to be a
conditional distribution.